all right we're doing it
welcome back to hot breath this is the
show where you learn comedy from the
pros i'm your host
comedian joel byers and we are all about
cultivating the next generation of great
comics
and our guest today i firmly believe
is part of that roster she is an example
of a comic creating her own success
overcoming all odds and not making
excuses but making progress
instead and that sounded very fancy i
should write that on a fortune cookie
but long story short of it is
she's making her own path in this game
and we're so excited to have her
on hot breath where we are all about
creating the next generation of great
self-made comics so without further ado
please
welcome to the hot breath verse the one
and only
zarna garg ladies and gentlemen let's
give her some love here hello zarna
namaste namaste joel
the hot breath universe thank you so
much for having me i know you guys stole
that from us but we're fine
it's already throwing shade i'm too
white to defend any
sort of appropriation listen after we
lost yoga to the west it was all over
for us anyway
well they well india lost you to the
west i mean you fled here
when you're 16 to avoid an arranged
marriage so i mean
we're doing something right here what a
mistake that was yeah
some foolishness what possessed me
oh i will make my own life with my
husband that is so much more work than
keeping one mother-in-law happy
what are they trying to go back now like
take me arrange me now if anybody wants
me
do you do you regret it no oh
god no you think this was meant to be
contained within a system that tells
women to be quiet all day long
that's incredible that yeah you escape a
system to where
you actually your job is to not be quiet
all day long exactly i mean look it's
been a long road to find this path
but clearly you know i feel strongly
that i was meant to do this i was just
miscast in a different role for the
first 40-something years of my life what
makes you
feel i feel like a lot of comics have
that feeling or a lot of aspiring comics
have that feeling of like oh i've
i i've always wanted to do this or i
feel like i should do this
what was that what made you feel like
you were born to do this and then how
did you actually decide to do it
um so i've written a screenplay and uh
that's
winning screenplay by the way a little
bit award-winning um come on
and you yeah and that i did out of
desperation i saw a big opening in the
market i
was like why are brown women always
perceived as sad
and like lonely and you know heavy
topics in the west which is by the way
true but there is another side to us
we're very fun we're happy people too
uh but once i wrote that i was still
struggling how to get my comedic voice
out there like i could
feel a tension inside me and my
daughter actually helped me make a
breakthrough i have a 16 year old
daughter who's now
almost 18 and she reached out to people
who've known me my whole life like 100
people
from people who knew me as a high
schooler to people who recently met me
and said can you write
a line or two about what you what your
favorite memory is about my mom
and uh she got a hundred notes back and
almost every single one said she made us
laugh
so my daughter gave me all these notes
and said if you don't do something with
this gift
i'm not sure what else the universe
needs to tell you
and that's the sad story of how you know
the sad beginning i cried i wept and
then i was like is there money in it
is there money in it because i've been a
volunteer for like 15 years as a mom
like can somebody pay me for something
yeah you go from being a lawyer to then
i'm gonna be a comedian
no i wasn't staying at her mom for 15
years stay-at-home mom for 15 years okay
yeah i mean listen i'm an immigrant and
that means certain things one of which
is that i have no support system in this
country and and like i don't it's not a
complaint it's just a fact
i don't have family here as soon as i
had kids the reality of like
who's gonna raise this thing yeah
no one tells you that after the cute
baby or i'm saying somebody's gotta be
with it all day
every day so uh for 15 years i was home
i mean i stopped i had to stop one of us
my husband or i
had to stop working and it was me and
that's a good thing because we would be
down one or two kids by now if it was
him
we would have lost one we would have
lost our first kid to malnourishment in
america
if my husband was in charge what does
what does that decision look like though
of okay i want to pursue comedy i see my
fate
looking me in the face but then what is
that conversation with your husband
what how do you then decide to do it
because a lot of people want to do
comedy but then
actually doing it is a whole other
animal
yeah i mean my i i'm very blessed my
family is
extremely supportive i thought you're
going to say extremely wealthy for
example
but listen okay if he wasn't paying the
bills i couldn't do it this is a fact
you know how this world is i
i get forget even the 20 club phase
have just started happening like and
then the club
shut down oh yeah but i you know
um you know when i started
i really thought i would do one or two
open mics five of my friends would watch
me and that would be the end of it
i didn't anticipate what ended up
happening to be honest with you
so i went and i told my husband i'm
gonna just go meet this lady who runs an
open mic i don't even know what an open
mic was
and she said go up and say anything i
was like anything
like really and yeah she's like just
whatever you find funny so i will never
forget the first line i said i got up
there and i looked around and i'm like
white people do this
ah that's hilarious the idea that you
can just stand there and like make jokes
and stuff and that could be a job
never occurred to me why people do this
so you didn't have any jokes written you
just went to an open mic
yeah i just started she said whatever
you find funny so i had you know i was
like
well i don't know why women wear high
heels that's ridiculous they were
designed for men and i started ranting
about all kinds of things
but my bigger takeaway that day and i
remember the moment when all the
comedians burst out laughing and we had
to connect
was when i said like you guys do this
every day like this is a thing
i don't think people in america realize
how extraordinarily rare
and privileged and special it is that
you can get up on a stage
and make fun of your president your
prime minister your this your that
without fear of persecution without fear
that
that you're gonna get attacked i mean i
could never do this in india
ever i wouldn't even dream of it how sic
how dangerous is it there i mean
recently an
indian female comedians uh joke was
discovered online a youtube joke about
hinduism
it's the mildest joke on earth it's
nothing evil or earth chattering
but somebody discovered it and they went
in they destroyed the club where it was
filmed they broke her house
comedians are routinely jailed in india
this is not uncommon you piss off the
wrong person and you don't even know who
the wrong person could be
because in an audience of a few hundred
who who's right and who's wrong
there are consequences i mean free
speech has a different meaning outside
america
and definitely in india i can't speak
for the whole world
but in the brown nation and especially
as a woman
i think the men get away with have a
little more levity
the men are like oh they're intellectual
they're making social commentary and the
women are being vulgar
that's what i i knew india has a newer
comedy scene
so i didn't know how um yeah how all
that played within
the actual just like cultural
expectations you know
so the established comedy scene in india
is extremely misogynistic
um make fun of women the women are the
punchline they
they're ridiculed on stage they're
pinched you won't believe this
you think like i sit here and i see the
stuff that gets people cancelled in
america and i start laughing i'm like
they only knew if they only knew what
goes on in the rest of the world
these women get on stage and like big
time like
bollywood stars will pinch them and be
like look how fat she is haha and that's
the joke
no one's actually ever written a joke
that's the joke
and like millions of people watch it and
tune in and like laugh at it
that's where that comedy seems well
you've
you have like over 13 million views on
tick tock i mean has there been any blow
back from
all that exposure yeah i mean my tick
tock comments are like wild
that my tick tock comment section is
like a twitter based of its own kind
like
i feel like with tiktok i have instagram
facebook and twitter combined to create
my tick tock account
because people get very passionate about
my jokes and what i'm talking about
but i have a huge i have a huge
contingent of supporters
so one person like pounces on me about
something and then a hundred other
people attack like it goes on all day
long
i've actually pulled one nerve on my
right arm just from responding to
tick-tock comments
it's like in the last four months and i
can't i keep up i try
and i try to stop the wars because i
don't really if somebody
you know is mean to me i don't care like
it doesn't you know listen
you know what goes on in the clubs here
i deal with a lot more
than that so i i'm not interested in
starting any war over this
but people do get passionate and i get a
lot of heat of course oh
she's making fun of her mother-in-law
because in-laws are so sacred in
india but how about the family
reaction they love it my husband
loves it like he can't wait he's like
get a netflix special so i can put you
on mute
[Laughter]
you know he no my kids love it they
understand what i'm doing
they're firmly behind my children are my
biggest source of strength and also like
i don't know who thought child labor was
a bad idea i think it's great
i made them work every show they're
working
every park show they my all three of my
kids one has to collect emails
one has to like give up hand sanitizer
in the world that we're in right now
a third one is selling water like you
know selling like gently suggesting
donations
wow so put them all to work
what about family in india though
my in-laws are on board and i think
when i first started everybody was
nervous like what's she gonna do
but the more i the more the business has
grown the more they see what i do
i think my screenplay uh my
screenwriting win
helped give me some credibility because
for two years all i was doing was
writing
you know when i was writing the
screenplay and i was like oh she's
writing and that means nothing to an
indian person
you like reading and writing they're
like what's that and why
you don't get paid for that if you tell
an indian person you're reading a book
they'll be like why
you know unless it's a math book then
you should read it
so um for two years they were just like
whatever she's writing and then like out
of nowhere that
you know this big honor came my way and
i think people sat up and this
took notice and now they see my comedy i
mean
i'm all about crafting a good joke i
take a lot of pride in writing
a good joke really working it i
i mean i love that this community exists
in america like i i
was so meant to belong in this world
no it's about hot breath hot breath
hundred percent the number one writing
community
the number one joke writing community in
the world wow
and i'm honored to be like you know to
be
in invited even though i stalk and do
all kinds of bad things too like i stalk
everybody's jokes i'm like would it be
right
what before we jumped on here you were
like wait you do all this for free
he's like well don't say that too loud i
don't want my wife to hear but
yeah i mean as of yes as of right now
well well we maybe we work together to
change that a little bit
i agree yes i'll um patch my wife in on
that call
yes but yeah it's uh it is i i just love
i've been doing comedy 10 years and i've
self-produced my own tours my own comedy
special
and this pot the podcast has been going
on five years and it's just
all about just helping comics get better
at comedy and this community
kind of grew from quarantine and
us not really knowing what the next step
is so i kind of
put all my attention online and now we
do the daily
joke writing club where there's comics
that tune in from australia at midnight
and there's there's comics in india in
the uk i mean all over the world
there's comics that tune into this every
day so it has it's really been very
rewarding but i do see where you're
saying but
every day for free huh well
that was a joke but not really but not
really
i didn't take it personally yeah no i
meant it as a compliment it's a lot of
work
you're so organized you're so methodical
you built this outstanding community
i mean this is stuff that people get
paid to do and it's a lot of work to do
it well
listen anybody can start a podcast and
anybody can start a
writing club but to do it at the level
at which you're doing it
that's a whole another level and i i
have a lot of appreciation for it
wow i appreciate you saying that zarna
thank you absolutely i
even when i don't write the joke i'm
always logging on to read it
read what people are doing oh wow yeah
today was like
episode 204 and i had a mental breakdown
so it only took 204 right 10 clubs for
me to have a breakdown
the audio wasn't working i i just yeah i
i kind of lost it and i was like well
then you make your own show
for the day yeah that was my joke for
the day for the day
listen but that's a part of running this
being part of this business i mean it
like you know online i'm sure you've had
your technical staff who's during snow
shows and stuff yeah i've had uh you
know i've had my issues and
you know it's we're all in this together
even though not really
as you know like we're not in this with
ellen degeneres for example
right but we're kind of sort of in this
together so
everybody gets it i think people have to
be forgiving of some of
this stuff yeah for sure but you how
long do you and if they're not and if
they're not i think you should push them
out of your free
open mic oh yeah well get out of here
free
freewheelers yeah come back tomorrow
see i can't even like commit to it
and it's people of all some people have
never even done comedy
because of quarantine so it's like
they're just learning how to write jokes
and then when live shows come back
they'll be getting on stage and things
like that but how
how long have you been doing comedy
specifically
it's a little over a year and a half now
what yeah i did my first
open like in april of uh 2019
yeah yeah let me explain something to
you
i'm i'm a little like mental like
little unstable in my mind like when i
want something
like my brain starts spinning like the
top until i get it like i can't
i can't control it it's actually manic
but truthfully i'm telling you
and you know a lot of comedians i think
are like that you may be too
because you've self-produced albums like
you can tell the comedian who's not
sitting around
waiting to be discovered it seems to me
that there's two at least two different
types of comedians
there's one that believes in the craft
and like honing every joke to the nth
degree of perfection and then like
waiting for that moment of discovery by
by a big agent
and then there's another class that's
like just grinding hard every day and
pushing through one obstacle after
another so
i feel just based on what i've seen of
the work that you do that you and i
might be cut from a similar cloth
for sure and that's that's the ethos of
hot breath
is i hope i use that word right i had to
use my 80 000
liberal arts degree somehow so i used
ethos but
it um yeah that's what we say every day
in here is
yeah we're creating our own success that
next generation
of great self-made comics like really
starting to
empower people regardless of how far
they are in their career or how much
they know about comedy
to start creating their own success and
opportunities and you being a year and a
half in like because
i've seen your stand-up and it's already
very funny so you already have like a
really good grasp of
just comedy writing i could tell just
from watching your stand up but then to
think
about how a lot of comics don't
understand this but it's called show
business and each one is a full-time job
to pursue
getting good at the show is a job and
then getting good at the business as a
job but you seem
to have really already been able to like
find an intersection between the two
that uh it's it's wow i a year and a
half i was not expecting that
wow no i am i think i started
with the focus and i have to i'm
i'm older than many comics who start
i have three kids i have a full plate of
responsibilities
i started going down this road
strategically that i have to focus on
the business side of it because
either it's a business or it's not for
me i don't have the luxury of taking it
on as a hobby
for too long i'm being honest with you i
just i would love it
i would love to luxuriate in doing open
mics and not worrying about how i'll
make money
but i i just can't i you know i can't
justify leaving
my kids and and whatever it costs to
replace me at home
um and it it makes me feel like i mean
it's it's um proof of concept
it's when people buy tickets when i'm
able to convert
my youtuber or my tick tocker to come to
a
club and buy a ticket now i know they
really like me
you know it's it's the only way that you
know it's for real
and uh you know i've been very blessed
in that way too the indian community is
firmly behind me in america
i had the first open mic i did they told
me can you bring five people and i was
like five
what will i do with the rest of them
they loved you no one had done so the
first open mic i had 90 people in the
audience
jeez and it was not like i didn't even
know what i was doing i just told my
friends like this american thing is
happening and they said come on stage
and make jokes
and they were like you know you'll make
jokes i said okay i'll make jokes about
her mother-in-law's thumb and then
everybody came what was your focus you
said you started with a focus what was
that focus
the focus was to always keep this
intersection merged the business and the
art
to not to understand like there are
jokes for example i'll give you an
example there's some jokes i do
that seem to get no traction on social
media i know it's not working
like i'll give you an example i cannot
tell a dirty joke to save my life
if i say [__] i'm not about to say that
it sounds like duck
no one like it doesn't fly so i tried it
i was like why can't i do this let me
try it and then
zero like negative so i'm always focused
on what's working and you know
any social media person will tell you
that you should isolate the things that
are working for you
on youtube tick tock instagram wherever
there's something there's some vibe that
people seem to appreciate consistently
so i'm constantly studying the analytics
behind what are the things that are
hitting in a big way
and how do i reiterate it in new and
different ways
and in some way it's not dissimilar from
writing a rom-com screenplay like when i
wrote
a movie screenplay for america
i was very focused on what is a
traditional romantic comedy grid
like you know boy meets girl like i
didn't want to be
so different that people are gonna be
like what is this
but within that grid how do i make it my
own and make it special
so now i'm doing the same thing in
comedy like within this comedy universe
of possibilities there's so many
comedians
who has successfully made like a you
know like a
business out of it and then how can i
emulate those steps
you know and stick with it with some
discipline
who have you been emulating um i
love like i love what sebastian
maniscalco
like all these people i discovered in
the last year and a half
so i like i only knew what most you know
i had seen seinfeld growing up
but you know the beginning monologue
that he does like i didn't know that
that's comedy like i never went to a
club
so uh but now i've learned so i've now
like russell peters masterful
businessman like i obsessively try to
read everything and of course he's also
indian so it's like
it's even an added bonus for me but
there was a strategic
business angle and he was lucky i think
he had his brother
helping and managing and uh
but i learned a lot and i i'm always
equally obsessed as obsessed as i am
with writing a good joke
i'm constantly obsessed with how did
people make it happen
yeah that's that's a good tip to look at
who's doing
what you want to do and see how you can
emulate it
i think it's a good starting place in
the end you all we all have to find our
own path
but some some wheels have been
you know have been invented already so
let's not reinvent those
that's that's how i feel what other kind
of business tips do you have for comics
um i think defend your price
you know name a price and defend it like
you it's a it's a little bit of an
art i do a lot of zoom shows now zoom
private parties and zoom this and zoom
that
and uh i decided early on that i set a
certain price for what it will cost for
a private event i'm not talking about
a club event or whatever and i got i get
pushed back here and there and
you know i've learned now to say no i'm
sorry i
have to you know you get what you ask
for
at the end of the day and you have to
fight for it
and you know and that's not new to me i
mean i've
you know that that's just not new to me
i i've had to fight for so many things
in my life
and now i'm learning that the more i
stick with their people who will say no
i'm we're not doing this and then three
months later come back to me
and be like okay you know why do i or
find a solution i always help people
find solutions like why don't we have
two parties merge together
and then it's a little more cost
effective and you know but
uh i think defend what you think you're
worth because what you think you're
worth is what the industry is going to
think you're worth eventually
that's good yeah because if you don't
value yourself why will anybody else
and that's interesting when you
mentioned earlier about
looking for ways you can
create your own path in the game and
people are just now
starting to get into zoom shows and it
seems you're creating a business
around zoom shows i did immediately in
march
we had a lockdown for a week i was like
blown away because i lost all my shows
i was scheduled to be in the new york
comedy festival that was gone
everything that i was excited about gone
in a week
so for a week i was like out of it but
then i said you know what
there's always an opportunity hiding in
this kind of madness
that's just how it is and so i started
doing zoom shows and i like i now
believe that in in during the actual
main lockdown you know when
everything was shot i lost all my new
york friends because i couldn't meet
anybody even the people i knew in the
city
but i found a whole world of friends
outside
because i would just sit on my computer
and like try this and try
that and at that time people were so
forgiving
anything you know to get a little bit of
a laugh
so just like the experience you're
having with joke writing
i had with my comedy i would be like hey
i'm happy to do a show in australia time
will
let's see if somebody logs in and i
would put an insta story out
and like 10 people would log in to watch
a free show
on ig live and then that became like my
base for like hey if i
if you ever want to book me for a party
i'm available
you know so it's like it's very slow
it's painstaking but it got me a start
in a new market
that how else would i ever access
sitting here in new york
and you gosh this is so such great
timing because i was just
thinking this past weekend about the
business opportunity within
doing zoom shows and i've done a few for
family friends but i just see
the potential yeah beyond like zoom
parties corporate
events and things like that i think can
all be done via zoom
yeah and it's being done now because
these corporate
events like for example the corporate
meetings and stuff that happened they're
so boring they know it the zoom fatigue
is real
yeah like i like it there's actually i i
believe there's a whole thing about
in february march when zoom first
started like we were all so formal we
sat down we took a little bite on the
side
and shut off the camera we were all
civilized in july
like drinking a little little drinking
drinking and then now we're like we're
taking a shower in the background
you know zooms out and no one cares
right right right
but it's it's tough is it's tedious it's
boring it's what i hear from corporate
uh people that i reach out to and
having 10 minutes of a real comedian is
nothing to
they used to do corporate lunches that
would have been like 20 people
going to a restaurant and ordering all
kinds of like
all of that is gone all those budgets
are sitting around now
just got me excited yeah see
there it is yeah you see
the roads if you keep thinking about it
avenues will open up i mean i reach out
to companies every week
hey would you consider adding a comedian
do you have a show are you celebrating
something
or even just in an annual meeting like
maybe you're crying
maybe you're crying like a lot of
companies are
let me help ease the pain and you'll
just do like 10 minutes
that's what you offer and they don't i
mean
i do traditionally the zoom shows i do
are about 20 minutes but i find in a
corporate setting even 10 minutes is
enough it's enough to break the tension
to make people relax about whatever it
is that they're doing and i'm in and out
and now people are so used to people
going in and out of zoom meetings that
it's it's just not even unusual anymore
how are you reaching out to them how are
you finding these businesses
and are you these friends or how yeah
how are you starting to reach out to
these people
uh my friends that way i've been very
useless
they only want to come out and have a
good time so they'll come out of the
clubs and all
but they this this avenue i have kind of
developed myself
okay i've gone down the path of like how
many companies have
indian employees like lots of them so
think about it all the tech companies
all the engineering companies all the
hospitals i've done so many shows for
big hospitals
you know who needs a laugh right now
medical staff
those i do for free i did for free all
summer like
a mount sinai or this hospital that
hospital
but what it does is if say 50 medical
staff personnel see me
and if one or two of them is having a
private event then they can think about
it as an option
so it's a win-win for everybody you know
and it's a short show
some of sometimes people log in from
their cell phones mm-hmm
just watch a few jokes yeah
oh that's very smart so i'm thinking
like you know my comedy special's called
the trophy husband
so it's almost thinking about businesses
within
like the wedding industry or planning
industry or
something maybe there could be something
there
well there's zoom wedding's happening
now
so there are zoom weddings yeah
absolutely
zoom bachelorette parties zoom weddings
there's everything
is moving to zoom and and and
i think even the world does open up
whenever that
is some aspect of this will remain
because it's just so easy i agree
it's like i don't think it's going away
anytime soon if anything it will only
become more sophisticated there will be
more bells and whistles
in the app itself so you can do a lot
more
so you're you're researching companies
that have
like indian employees and then are who
are you emailing or do you have a press
kit
attached like i have a press kit on my
uh
on my website that's one of the first
things i did because it's basically like
a business calling card
look i was never part of the club hang
like i was never
hanging out with people i didn't have
the ability to do that so
i had to find creative ways to make
myself known
to somebody who was interested in buying
a comedy unit
you know um so i have a press kit
but doctors like it started even small
like for example
my own doctor my personal uh you know
what is it called in america family
doctor
him when i went to him i said like hey
you know you guys look so stressed out
what are you doing in here let's do a
joke like let me do a five minute show
and i would try to get it so my kids
luckily i have so many kids because i'm
indian
i just kept giving birth for years so
this pediatrician they're dentists
they're orthodontists
whoever anywhere anywhere i went i was
like
listen i'm happy to do a 10-minute show
next time you guys have a zoom meeting
and i was like very surprised when
people started
and so initially i did a lot for free
okay just to
you know just to get the word out and
then from those shows
word started spreading oh you know what
she's funny like if you're having a
family gathering why not have her for 10
minutes
oh okay and then it started becoming
more paid events
yeah and are you making you don't have
to tell me numbers
on air but maybe after but um are you
making like as much as you would for a
live show
doing these well
okay so if i produced a live show and i
performed in it i made decent money
because
the ticket sales and all that exactly
yeah
but if i was on somebody else's show i
made nothing
i mean as you know it's very it's
minuscule
so the answer to that is yes and no of
course if i'm producing a sold out show
myself at caroline's
a 20-minute zoom show is not going to
compete with that
but but think of how much work you do to
get there
like when i did my short lines it was
it was an insane grind to make sure
every last ticket was sold and that it
was a full house and that i was bringing
value
to this club that chose to
uh give me a shot i mean i was so
new when caroline's gave me a show so i
understood
what they were doing and i wanted to
bring a lot of value to that that was a
lot of work compared to a 20-minute zoom
show
where you know so relative to how much
work it is i think i'm i'm making decent
money and
and honestly right now it's keeping me
going what else
the options are limited you know as you
know
yeah you've yeah you've really inspired
me and hopefully people watching and
listening
to um really look at this as a
opportunity i like how you're framing
all of this as
well you could see it as positive or
negative and you can like
sulk or you can get to work and you're
you're getting to work in
a a year and a half it's just that's
yeah that's
wow i'm i'm just i'm i'm impressed it's
it's inspiring
really i don't think don't be impressed
it took me 40 something years to get
here
you know it was a long road to figuring
out that comedy is
like now in hindsight even i'm like what
was i crazy did i not know comedy
existed
but it's culturally not what my people
do
like laughing no like i make jokes about
this don't worry be happy would never be
an indian song
our mantra is don't happy be worried
always she's saying people in india like
don't laughter is not a thing
not at this type of comedy so that the
type of comedy they laugh at is what i
described earlier it's
you know they don't understand that that
well-crafted joke
and and that if somebody is making a
joke about you
it's not necessarily a mean-spirited
punch
it's just observational so this whole
thing
is waiting to be discovered i think
there's a whole that's part of why i
think i'm getting a little bit
more traction than some others because
indian people for the first time if you
go through my tick tock comments
that just blows up with like an indian
woman is doing comedy and then they
forward it to like 50 people
awesome because it's not been done and
and i'm so happy that i i'm i'm putting
my voice out there and doing it
and i can only do it in america i'll
tell you that
because i'm part of communities like
yours
oh well thank you zarna yeah it's true i
i watch i'm telling you i read all the
jokes every day i'm like what are they
working on today
let me see for free for free she said
for free again
well this is a good deal
it's yeah you know why not
it's a free writing club and then we we
do have a paid facebook group where i do
workshops in there and
like my own q and a's and we do a
writing room in there
and there i do have an online comedy
writing course that also has a
podcasting course
and a live show production course
attached to it so
i'm gonna recommend that to all my
indian friends there's so many people
now
looking to make a break into comedy yeah
and i'm gonna recommend that straight
line to joel
thank you yeah let him know zarna knows
yes absolutely thank you zarin i
appreciate that
um oh this is a good question here and i
should have given um
angela moore asked about you your
pricing of your
zoom shows but i i should have said
angela moore asked but um
um yeah but you were just i i mean in
the are we can we say a hun
you're over a hundred dollars yes
i'll tell you it started at 250 for 20
25 minutes
there were several reasons for it it
didn't just come out of nowhere
uh i i did a little bit of calculation
that if i did
a show for corporates and there were x
number of people in the room i estimated
around 50.
uh i would do i did a little bit of math
i was like if they had gone out
how much would they have spent and how
do i make it a fractional amount and say
this is like five dollars a ticket or
something it's working out though
and that's how i started because you do
have to justify up you can't just be
like oh i want five thousand dollars and
for what
you know and it's so because a lot of
times you deal with hr
of a company so you explain to them like
five dollars you're talking buying them
a cup of coffee
essentially her head you know
so that's how i got started and now i
charge a little bit more and also i i
have
all these add-ons i can do custom jokes
uh now i write jokes for specific events
so our indian new year is coming
up so that's a whole custom event so
that's
that's separate from my usual jokes i
wrote a whole set for eid the
the the muslim new year that was a whole
add-on so now i've like branched out
into add-ons but
250 for 20 minutes was the starting
number
and and a lot of people said no by the
way i didn't get it easily and i still
don't get it easily it's it's a
marketing battle like anything else
but i stick with my price i would rather
sell
a few shows a month at that price and
really deliver amazing shows
then take any price i get not be excited
about it
you know so and i'm sticking with that
for now i mean ask me in a year i might
be crying who knows
i think you're striking into an untapped
market to be honest and i don't think i
don't think zoom shows are going
anywhere
i don't think they should go anywhere
you know like a lot of comedians don't
like them but i love it
i'm like yeah i plus plus i'm a mom like
no one listens to me anyway
so i'm now doing it on a screen
my household no one's listening i'm
doing comedy all day long no one's
paying me intention
but they're people that matter online
are paying attention
you know the people and i think what has
happened like
there have been zoom rooms where like
suddenly there's an agent that
you know will text me and be like hey
you know you start what are you doing
and whatever
i don't have representation right now
but uh
but i do there are there's always you
don't know who's in what room
you know you you booked the thing and
there's like fifty hundred people you
don't know who's who
and i'm just happy to get my word name
out there i'm
you know usually i'm just thrilled that
somebody's tuning in and listening
terms of like marketing and this is
something uh bob kirk
is asking if he's like if you look at
your day
how much time in a day would you be
marketing and selling yourself
versus writing and performing
uh marketing and selling
i really believe that the marketing is
the lifeline of the business
would i rather be doing the joke writing
and working on the jokes
absolutely because i love doing it but
the truth is that if i'm not on the
marketing grind
i can't do it for too long anyway
so as we were discussing earlier before
you know that
you know the podcast is also book it
takes time
the people don't realize how long it
takes to do something well
and then to bring it to a level where
you can sell
sell it and charge money for it so i
spend an
inordinate amount i i spend a lot of
time networking
i'm part of various networking groups uh
women's groups this group that group i'm
always in and out of zoom rooms learning
from other people like how they've grown
their businesses uh-huh
it's also something i like like it's i'm
interested in it i love
learning the strategies so what does
that 60
marketing look like what are you doing
you mentioned looking at social media
analytics what what other kind of
marketing tips do you have here like
i'll give you an example there's a
company called brunch works
okay now branch works is basically a
networking platform
and they invite experts from all kinds
of things
and you can pay like you know a 30 fee
or whatever and listen to them
and interact with them not just listen
interact with them
and they have like heads of studios
heads of entertainment companies the vp
of this the development head of that
so i if i see anything of any interest
i'm there like i if for 30 dollars i can
actually get a face to face for five
minutes
with somebody like that it's worth it to
me but
but you have to do a lot of those to
build one real relationship
you have to go into it more with the
idea that you're gonna learn from the
expertise and then
hope that there is a relationship so
that's a big part of what i do
uh in terms of marketing because it's
also two-way right
now they know that there's an indian
woman comedian who's doing this this and
this in new york
uh so i spend a lot of time in these
learning sessions
all day long like you said looking at
comedians and how you can emulate their
success the same thing
with other people outside of the comedy
industry
yeah any honestly any creative industry
would be totally relevant like any type
of creative field
works i'm working on writing an animated
series right now and
a lot of the animation studios offer
free networking
if you go through their web pages
they'll say we're doing a free zoom show
on how animation gets happens
now even if i don't really want to know
how animation really happens because all
i want to do is write
by being in that room i'm entering that
matrix
now they know that i'm writing something
i know that they know
other people who are buying writing so
but you cannot the mistake i see people
make
is that they'll go to three things and
say i never heard back
you know it didn't really it's it's not
like that you've got to truly enjoy the
process
and put yourself out there and it's a
lot of time there's just no way around
it
and then i think they start clicking
yeah it's not like you're you're putting
out a lot you're not just
reaching out to three people and they're
all like yeah come on down it's like
it's like joke writing you write 20
jokes and maybe one sticks
exactly and it's the same you know and
that's the same in any business it's not
even creative it's a you know
yeah yeah and bob followed up with what
media
do you how wait what
media do you sell through how do you
reach your potential clients
uh for my zoom shows i think people are
interested in that
so i email everyone people with requests
and it's a lot of cold emails it's a lot
of cold emails to hr
a lot of cold emails to doctor offices
my neighborhood offices i try to hit
small businesses now i do free park
shows
you know i for the life of me can't get
a spot on anybody else's show so i just
started producing my own show i was like
all right
you know let's see what it takes but
when i have people there i'll pass out
information on zoom
events that they can hire me for oh
so if so why do you think i have all
these kids i'd like i make myself
hold on to everybody why do you think i
have
these kids
oh that's so good i was thinking ahead
18 years ago it was all in there
it's so good yeah oh my god
and if they had fun then they might
consider me for a zoom part
you know what i mean like if they
thought that they enjoyed what i did
then they might consider it
so yes oh you're always promoting your
zoom shows even if you're doing a free
that's that's so good i am i am
what's great and like how long it took
for this to get scheduled but then the
timing of it actually happening could
not
be more perfect for this is like right
i think probably a lot of comics are
thinking of like man i'm doing a lot of
zoom shows there's probably some sort of
way to make money on this but
yeah like it it's all like sparking i
think at this instance and it's so
generous of you because
this what you're also representing right
now
is like when we think about that next
generation of great comics how you're
saying
for the life of me i can't even get on
someone else's show
i've i went through that so like in my
own comedy scene of like i
i just want to get on stage so i can get
funny but there's clicks
and there's cool kids and what we're
trying to do here
through a hot breath is like hey there's
enough room for everyone
there's enough you we can like we're
interviewing all these comics and
they're like here's how i did it
go do it type deal and at the end of the
day you've just got to be willing to put
in the work
and most people aren't willing to do
the work yeah i mean i am not like i
give all secrets away people you know
when i ask
often people are secretive and i don't
really understand it because
first of all it's nothing proprietary
about any of these ideas
and second i i believe rising tides lift
all boats yes you know yes i think we
can work together to make comedy
a thing again and and lift all of us up
together
uh you know we're not competing with
each other it's not that small if you
look at
how much money comedy generates for the
social media platforms
you really realize how much money there
is to be made how much content we give
away for free to facebook instagram tick
tock youtube
what do you think they're doing they're
monetizing all our work
that's how they become what they become
right so there is a lot of room for
growth
we just have to find it and with
tick-tock uh i'm one of the newest
members of their creators fund
so now i yeah so now i talk to them and
you know
i get like you know like i'll push back
with them too
they took me on as a creator they want
to support and i appreciate that so much
but i'm also bringing a new and unique
voice to the table
so i feel like all of us have to
together say we're doing all this work
we're bringing all this to the table
this is how you youtube get a billion
views
because of all the comedians people log
on and just
search comedy any time of the day and
like watch
work that we grind hard to produce so i
think there's so much room
for growth for all of us instead of
thinking of it as a saturated market
which some people choose to i know i
think that the potential
and by the way if this year has taught
us anything
we all need to laugh more yes
for sure and i think that scarcity
mentality is of
the old comedy mindset like we talked
before we got on here of
there's an old mindset within the
creative space but especially comedy of
like
you shouldn't make money or you're
somehow taking advantage of the craft in
a sense that's an old mindset that i am
having to break myself out of as well
but it's great to connect with comics
like you who have
broken through that or setting the new
standard of that next generation
in comedy that we're talking about it's
well i think in the old days it's
and i wasn't here when this was true
because it all changed this year
uh people waited for that late night
spot
it was all about the credit and the late
night spot and the
you know the big festivals and all that
like i think i
started comedy knowing no one's giving
me a spot so i just have to find like my
own way
i mean i i and in some way it became a
blessing because i
because it's not a path i ever really
actively pursued
and and now look at where we are the
digital world has upended that
in such a big way who knows what's going
to be the new thing next year
yeah you know so i think that that
scarcity mentality was tied to like how
many people can silent have on at a time
so we're all fighting for those same
four five ten spots but
it's just not true anymore like there
can be 200 of us
with a hot million people account each
on social media
and will still not even be a drop in the
social media ocean
june is asking about your audio and
video equipment did you invest
it's a two-parter did you invest in
audio and video equipment
for your zoom shows and do you sit or
stand during your zoom
shows i invested in a state-of-the-art
macbook pro laptop because
uh once i realized that we're going full
digital i bought the
the newest macbook with with the biggest
capacity that i could it was expensive i
was like
i was so angry how expensive it was
uh i do my comedy sitting down because i
feel like this is my most
personal like it feels like you're
having a conversation
uh but i've seen people doing it
standing up
i think you have to do what makes you
feel most grounded and ready to deliver
but i do believe equipment is you have
to have it like
that's key like if you're charging money
whether it's 25 bucks or 250 or 25
000 i think you have to respect the fact
that that person is paying and it can it
has to be flawless you cannot have
technical glitches and you cannot have
sound
conking up on you so i invested a lot
upfront in the equipment do you have a
microphone as well or is it you're
you're using your
headpiece there i have five different
microphones here
as options but nothing seems to work as
well as this does
interesting i have i have like the big
podcast mic i have everything
but nothing seems to work and i
personally
i'm very animated when i'm doing my
comedy so being hands-free also helps
like i don't have anything in front of
me i can do you know
yeah and as we're as we're landing this
plane here
you've you've been able to generate a
lot of momentum on
social media i mean all
clearly off social media and turning
into a business but like how
what kind of social media marketing tips
do you have even from
the content to release how often to
release it are you scheduling it like
social media can become your full-time
job it can also become a full-time
distraction
if you're not using it effectively
completely
and i'm learning this is a learning
curve for me
i am more organized about it i have a i
have a release schedule now so i try to
release two
funny bits a week what i have found
is that people actually like knowing the
story behind the story
you know the kids the husband even the
mother-in-law
and by the way just a word about my
mother-in-law the woman couldn't speak a
word of english until last year
miraculously this year she's like i
think you owe me money
that's the only sentence she learned how
to speak so
um people love so i have to my tenth
poll on every social media
platform is two jokes a week minimum
okay
and then like you know a story about
something that i could be doing a show
or my husband or my kid or the other kid
or the third kid as i said i have many
or something that's going on in the
world elections or whatever
you know people do i used to be very
nervous that i have to be funny in every
post
and then i realized that it was actually
my emotional posts that were doing
better than my funny pose
like people were enjoying learning about
what i'm about and i think it's true
now that i think like when i go to your
page i love reading about you know your
wife or like what your life
is i get the jokes but i also want to
get
why joel does what he does why is he
doing this writing club
why did he start so i i recommend that
everybody you know
a release schedule for some funny
content
and then like other things around them
and consistency of course
and resist the urge twitter oh my god
it will suck you in and you know before
you know it you're at war about like
i don't know mayonnaise yep that's such
a great example
who even cares the next day it's like
but you got sucked in in the moment and
i am guilty of it i've done
i've done my share of tweets where i've
woken up and been like what was i
thinking
but i'm trying to limit those i'm trying
to limit those
awesome man this i i mean
we have done so many of these and this
i think this is my favorite i mean we
just had jeff foxworthy on here and i
feel like
this i i feel like i got more out of
this one than that one um
yeah you're wow i'm
moved i mean i i'm moved right now zarno
like i really feel like i knew like
spark
in my step in terms of what is possible
with this time because like you said
i have and we have like people tune in
every day to the writing club but it's
like that's been a daily thing
still releasing a weekly podcast and
still look like doing
youtube as a whole animal as well and
like now you you
feel like you've added a lot of clarity
to a lot of comics
about how they can optimize what the
current situation we're in and
start creating their own success so
thank thank you zarna this this has been
amazing
no thank you as i said i'm so happy to
be here and
you know zarna has a lot of things but
above all she's grateful i'm very
grateful
oh my gosh i discovered that about
myself as well
this i did an exercise where i listed a
hundred things about myself
and then and then the exercise was to
pick one of those things
and grateful was the one thing that i
narrowed it all the way down to
you know what i'm not surprised because
they say that
they say that success success is usually
directly proportionate to how grateful
you are
wow and and i i that's why i'm not
surprised you're saying that the re
that's what's that's what's giving you
that purpose to keep doing the free
stuff
and then lead to conversion converting
to the other stuff
uh but it comes from a place of
believing like i if i you know listen
i'm
about 10 seconds old in this business
and who am i and what am i going to say
but i wish that more comedians believe
that there is a lot of power and
collaboration
and that together we can win this thing
that almost took us down and our
industry down this year could end up
being
the biggest boon for us in the next five
years
um namaste yes that was even got a
meditation moment
that was beautiful oh my gosh yes i mean
zarna where can people follow you
support you reach out to book you on
your zoom shows like
please promote whatever it is that we
can help promote here
my website zarnagart.com has all my
information
my tic toc everywhere it's at zarnagaard
except facebook where i'm zanagar
official for what reason i have no idea
because various
handle issues but i'm very easy to find
all over
and i would love to support everybody
back this is not a one-sided
relationship
they support me i support them if
there's anything i can do
to help anybody i'm here and i want to
be a part of the community and i'm
very grateful that you invited me oh
thank you well you are
definitely an official member of the hot
breath of verse we're happy to have you
people are saying in the hot breath ship
zarna put wind in our sails
today um that's amazing
yes believe people believe i believe
could you the last thing we we do on
here is we have our guest uh
look into the camera say their name and
then why
comics should listen to uh hot breath
uh my name is zarna garg and comics
should listen to hot breath because this
is where the next generation of great
comedians is going to come from
so be part of that club bow
zarna garg hop brethren and sisterin
beautiful beautiful let me get a
applause sound effect
so good go forth with your days
hot brother and sister and you now have
the road map to start creating your own
success
in these turbulent times so this q a
took place
in our facebook group so if you're
watching this on youtube or listening to
it
after the fact on our podcast go into
the show notes
click join this facebook group you'll be
a part of our writing club
and our weekly feedback mics these q as
and so much more
so until next week hop read the verse
have a good day bye bye
namaste namaste
you